On the structure of the glider charts.
As I said, when you look at one for the first time,
and you're not used to dealing with such charts,
it can almost feel a bit intimidating.
At least, that's how it looked to me
at the start, when I first sat down with one.
But if you look at how the chart is built up from the ground up,
and at all the boxes drawn on it,
and the wavy lines on the chart,
then it's actually,
well, not that complicated.
Then you know in principle
what the boxes and wavy lines mean.
And after that it's just an awful lot of detail packed on top.
And sometimes it's still tricky
to figure out which wavy line belongs to which airspace.
But that's mostly a visual challenge.
So, to build an understanding of the charts,
I'm going to try,
to show you a bit
and build the chart up from the ground.
First of all,
there are lines you know,
the dividing lines between the Mittelland and the Jura,
and the Alps.
It actually runs
right across Switzerland,
roughly from Lake Geneva,
near Montreux,
it cuts across central Switzerland,
all the way to us,
into the eastern Alpine region,
and from there on into Austria.
And that's how Switzerland gets divided up.
And there's simply a topographical reason behind it,
namely that in the Jura and the Mittelland
all the mountains are much lower,
and in the Alps they're quite a bit higher.
And so the airspaces are pushed up a bit higher there.
And that has an impact
on us as paraglider pilots.
Now let me explain.
As I said,
in G and E
we can fly any time,
and in C and D
we need a clearance.
And G,
we can simply picture it
as the blue band,
like a carpet,
laid across the whole of Switzerland,
sliding across the entire topographical chart.
And that carpet is 600 m thick.
And the transition,
once you're above those 600 m,
you go into E.
There we're still allowed to fly.
It's just a different airspace,
with different rules.
But for us as paraglider pilots
we can fly in both of them.
Then it gets interesting for us,
namely where the boundary is,
where E ends
and C takes over,
and we're no longer allowed to climb further,
even in super thermals.
At some point we have to say,
okay, even though there's still a strong climb,
we'd still rise further.
The cloud base might be higher up,
but we have to step out of the lift.
And make sure we don't enter C.
And that's where it gets really crucial,
and also really important,
that you know where the boundary is.
In the Jura,
so everything
to the left of the dividing line,
the boundary is at 3050 m.
In the Alps
the boundary is at 4550 m.
So you can already see there's quite a difference
in altitude,
and of course also in the opportunities
we have with the paraglider.
Something very important to know,
exactly,
if a mountain there happens to be 4200 m high,
you're still allowed to fly 600 m above it.
So in that case you can actually fly up to 4800 m.
And yes,
clearly above the 4550.
The condition is simply,
well, yes,
1050 m past that boundary, only this one time.
up to 3950 m.
Below that we still have the military hours.
Those are also on the glider chart, and very important.
It's always Monday through Friday, from 07:30 until 12:05.
And from 13:15 until 17:15.
The five minutes are simply to exclude any overlap.
So that there's definitely no collision or incident.
So very important, when the military is active,
the boundary in the Alps drops a bit lower.
But it's still clearly higher than in the Jura and the Mittelland.
So just to recap quickly,
the transition from E to C in the Mittelland is at 3050.
In the Alps it varies depending on military activity.
One small point,
I forgot it earlier with all the airspaces,
is airspace D, which is also controlled
and where you may also need a clearance and radio contact.
That comes into play above all near airfields.
So we have G.
The carpet that goes over the topography,
above that E, and 3050.
And D comes in mainly around airfields.
All these airspaces are marked with so-called text labels.
Here we see on the left the theory and on the right,
what it looks like on the chart.
The labels always show a lower limit and an upper limit.
And here it's very important
to know the difference between upright numbers and italic numbers.
If it's upright, it's above ground.
If it's italic, it's above sea level.
And the second big difference
I've noticed with the numbers
is that the upper-limit numbers are blue and italic.
Italic numbers also mean
the altitude is in standard atmosphere.
Now we see how in paragliding
or in paragliding theory,
all topics are always interrelated
and somehow connected to another grip.
In meteorology you've already heard a lot about standard atmosphere.
Now it's exactly the same idea,
namely that a standard pressure is also used here.
And so the white numbers
are the actual altitude,
so if you use the GPS measurement for example,
or something on the mountains or measured by altitude,
so really the actual altitude on the gauge.
And the blue italic numbers,
those are numbers that fluctuate with the weather,
because they're simply pressure-based,
at sea level.
And always assume
that at sea level the same pressure is used,
namely 1013.25 hectopascals.
And why exactly that is,
we'll try in the next few slides
to bring across a bit.
The altitude that we measure
is done via a pressure measurement.
That means
any device measures a certain pressure,
except for altitude measurement with GPS,
but also,
the ground,
also,
(unclear),
is the quarter.
And with the stove and with the device specified.
We can also suggest the millibar.
That means
also,
the devices,
(unclear),
the meme of the stiff,
During the day the pressure can shift too, and by the evening after landing
your altimeter can already be off by a few metres.
And to deal with that, a solution was found, and that solution is called
flight levels — flight surfaces — and it comes from international aviation,
because aircraft that fly from one airport to another, over long distances,
fly through different weather zones and different pressure regions.
And that means you'd actually have to recalibrate the altimeter every few metres, right?
Yes, every few kilometres of flight you'd have to recalibrate, reset the ground pressure.
You'd have to keep radioing in: what's the weather, what's the pressure on the ground,
so that the altitude is correct. And that would be almost impossible and extremely time-consuming.
And it would also carry the risk of running the same calculation errors,
or that pressure shifts get mixed up and lead to discrepancies.
So in aviation it was agreed that you don't fly by actual
altitude, but by standard pressure.
Standard pressure, as I said, 1013.25 hectopascals at sea level.
And now here's a quick calculation example, before we get into flight levels.
And how it works in practice, just so we get an idea of what it means.
So the example with Flight Level 100, a flight level is 100 feet.
That means Flight Level 100 is 10,000 feet, and because 1 foot is 30.48 centimetres tall,
Flight Level 100 is then 3000 metres and 48 centimetres.
And now you can see the connection.
Or yes, we can explain why for example in the Jura, the level or the airspace
starts at 3050 metres.
That's actually Flight Level 100, and it comes from airline aviation.
And in the same way, in the Alps the 3050 metres is Flight Level 100, and the 4550
is Flight Level 150.
And down low it's of course important that an aircraft flies at the exact altitude,
simply because of the topography, so there's no collision with mountains or obstacles.
But at a certain altitude it doesn't really matter so much, since the aircraft pass each other or run alongside.
The most important thing is just that the aircraft are separated and not flying at the same altitude.
And that's exactly what was achieved with the flight level — the goal was reached.
As we see, if an aircraft flies from a high-pressure region into a low,
it doesn't have to be such an extreme curve, of course; here it's shown a bit exaggerated.
But then the flight level shifts a little.
So the aircraft swims along a bit, dropping slightly here and there.
But it's always at the same pressure, so the aircraft is exactly on the same pressure surface.
And then it doesn't really matter whether it's at 11,000 or at 10,900,
what's important is that aircraft fly at different levels so collisions can be avoided.
Also on the glider chart, this is mainly the case with the TMAs and the Airways.
We'll come back to those later, but if you look at the labels here,
with airspace D, they always have a lower limit.
Here it's the ground.
Here we also have lower limits of 2500 and 2600.
And those are fixed.
It's very important that they're fixed, because of the topography.
This is the example of Meiringen, which has very high mountains to the left and right.
The upper limit, the 5300, that's where we're back in the range
where it doesn't really matter, because there are no more obstacles.
That altitude can fluctuate.
And that's explained on this slide as well.
So we have the topography, the lower limit is very strict,
because if the pressure fluctuated there, we'd have problems.
Then an aircraft could cut through, right into the mountain.
It could run into the topography and cause a collision.
The upper limit, though, that can fluctuate.
And how much it varies, you can see here.
This is also interesting to know when we're flying with the glider.
By the way, the cells are shown on the glider chart.
So, you see, at 1037 hectopascals.
Ground pressure.
And that's already, well, calculated as ground pressure.
That's of course very high pressure.
And there it makes about 200 m difference.
Whereas in very low pressure, it's about minus 200 m.
So it's actually quite a lot, though it should be said
that in such low pressure we probably won't be flying.
Normally, because the weather is just very bad and storms are coming in.
In an extremely high pressure situation,
we might do a soaring flight from a high alp into the mountain.
But probably less of a thermal flight, because the air is just too stable.
Now we're slipping back into meteorology a bit.
But mostly we're in the range of maybe plus,
perhaps even up to 100 m of difference when thermalling.
And the good thing is that the deviation works in our favour.
So when you know an airspace starts at 3050,
and we're thermalling, it's usually a bit higher in practice.
But it's still important that the device is set correctly
and that you don't fly off based on a wrong reading.
Now for a change, a sample exam question,
which also comes up in the paragliding theory exam.
We see here the upper limit of airspace class E over the Jura.
Then we first have to think: how high would it be normally?
In the Jura, we said, it doesn't matter whether the military is active or not,
the upper limit for us is at 3050.
Now we have a very strong high pressure.
At first glance, you see lots of numbers and you get the feeling,
oh wow, I have to do a precise calculation here and so on.
But actually you're not expected to be able to do such a calculation.
We've simply seen,
since it's an incredibly strong high,
in a very strong high it makes a maximum of about 200 m difference.
And here we quickly see three, three, three or four E-options.
Of course we have way too many.
So it doesn't make that much difference,
it always stays within a range of plus or minus 200 m.
In case there's an exam question on it.
Now we've made a small detour into flight levels.
Yes, drifting a bit away from the glider chart.
But also necessary for understanding how the airspaces are built up.
I hope it helped a bit.
Now we can come back to the other airspaces.
Here are the airspaces D, which I mentioned briefly before.
These are the so-called control zones,
which are right in the immediate vicinity of the major airports.
And they always go from the ground up to a certain altitude.
Their shape is of course very topography-dependent
and also depends on the approach corridors
and on the needs of the airport.
And they're of course not always round.
Here it's just shown as a simple shape.
D
With the TMAs there's something special.
So, for example, I have a sector,
a TMA that runs into a mountain or into the topography.
That happens sometimes.
And here it's important to know that with the paraglider,
but careful, only south of the dividing line with the Alps, so only in the Alps,
you may fly 300 m below it.
This applies in only a few cases.
There's also an exam question that's a bit tricky,
where you can fall in, so watch out with that 300 m rule.
Of course there are launch sites where you, for example, take off here
and fly out beautifully under those 300 m down below.
And you're absolutely legal at all times,
and don't need a clearance for it either.
Then we have the airways.
They connect the major airports
and also the main routes of international air traffic.
Here's a small view from Sion.
We see, there are multiple TMAs — five, six, seven TMAs,
or sometimes just one, it really varies.
And as I said, it depends entirely on air traffic and the topography
around the airport.
The activity of the various TMAs differs too,
if 9 is shown — so if the designation CTR, LSZR,
if it says H24, then it's permanently active,
like for example Zurich with the big airport.
When it says HX, then there are no fixed operating hours.
But you basically have to assume
that it's active at any time, and you can check the status.
And then there are the temporary ones.
The temporary ones are announced via DABS
when they're active.
There are only two cases in Switzerland.
Sion and Altenrhein, for example, we'll come back to that later.
There are three activity statuses of TMAs and CTRs.
We have quite a few heliports in Switzerland,
they're marked like this, and we have to keep a radius
of 2.5 km away from them.
The smaller airfields without CTRs are marked like this.
They have a radius of 5 km that we need to keep distance from.
Here we have ten examples.
There in the Lucerne area, that's a bit of a Bermuda triangle for us.
We paraglider pilots, who we have to be quite careful,
to make sure we never enter an airspace.
But a really nice flying area.
And we can definitely fly there.
But it's currently very, very complex.
Here you can also see all the examples
that exist.
There's a heliport with 2.5 km.
The civilian airfields, then there are mixed airfields
used for both military and civilian purposes.
Then there are purely military airfields,
marked in red and crossed.
Interestingly, they only go up to 600 m above ground.
We're allowed to fly over them above those 600 m.
Or, well, without getting into trouble.
On this topic it's also important,
if you're on a cross-country flight,
and you have the feeling,
well, my ideal flight route and thermals
and the glide angle and so on.
My route goes right through there.
Or we go just barely
clipping a heliport.
Then it's a sure thing,
you should be in contact beforehand.
And with the SHV, with the local clubs,
they'll check whether at that heliport
there's perhaps a local arrangement in place.
If you don't have prior info,
then you always have to assume.
It's a 2.5 km radius
and 5 km radius at airfields, and 600 m.
Maybe, like in this case here,
where it's cut into a specific shape,
where there's a transit corridor through it.
And you also see
that ground goes up to 1200 m here.
Above that it goes up to 800-900 m.
That means it's clearly less than 600 m.
And that can be very helpful,
later in practice,
if you just have this kind of information.
Then on the glider chart, obstacles are also marked,
looking roughly like this.
Here, for example, the Säntis.
We have the obstacle drawn at the top,
and that it has a light,
which is more relevant for aircraft
that are out at night,
the fact that it's lit is less interesting for us.
What is interesting for us is,
the heights shown,
and here we get into italic script
and upright script.
Italic means above sea level,
so that's the tip of the antenna,
and the 124 m in upright script,
that's how tall it is in real terms.
So you know,
okay, the antenna is this big,
so you can see it from a distance and so on.
Yes, that's just a reference point.
Also important are the cables
that are marked.
With the 1264 m
that's just the highest distance above the ground.
So we can estimate
how long the cable is.
Very important,
watch out,
not every obstacle is on the glider chart.
There are heaps of obstacles
that aren't on it.
For that you should also check the aviation obstacle charts,
and even when you've checked them,
fly with your eyes open.
Don't just fly blindly into somewhere,
because there can always be
some piece of wood
or a cable hanging somewhere,
that, legally, doesn't have to be marked,
doesn't need to be flagged,
and which then,
yeah,
could become your undoing.
So always fly with your eyes on,
and also with the local pilots,
and at the clubs and associations,
and also at the stations
of the cable cars,
where you'll usually find very good info
on aviation obstacles.
On this topic,
don't rely 100% on the glider chart alone.
There are also quite a lot of these,
the LSRs, the red ones,
the red Rs, they're restricted.
So they're a no-go,
you can't fly there.
On the glider charts
the ones marked
are those that are very often active,
drawn in,
and afterwards again
we go into DABS,
the evening before,
to check,
whether it's actually active,
on the day,
when I'm flying or not.
Then there's
LSD.
That's not restricted.
That's Danger.
There you can basically
fly.
It's just not recommended,
because dangerous things can happen there.
We're talking about,
for example,
shooting on the ground,
and that you'd be allowed to fly into a live-firing area
in principle.
It's of course not recommended,
but in principle
not legally forbidden.
Here we have the example
of an LSR,
in our region,
above Albstein,
and in the Wäggital,
the LSR three.
And here,
as you see again,
a lower limit
and upper limit.
These are in red,
italic.
And that means,
again,
it's in standard atmosphere,
and that the boundary
of the military training area
can fluctuate.
fluctuate.
It can be a bit higher,
or a bit lower.
Exactly,
to show that a bit better,
so you can see what's going on,
a quick explanation of DABS,
you'll find DABS
at www.skybriefing.com.
Right at the first step,
very important,
always check that the date is correct,
because if you look at the wrong day
by mistake,
you might feel,
everything's clear,
I can fly anywhere.
And on that day,
when you're flying,
some live-firing exercises are actually taking place,
that's of course very, very unfavourable, so,
people,
always very,
very important,
that the date is correct.
Now,
as you see on this chart,
the LSR drawn in red
are not very widespread.
They're not very active.
By the way,
in our area,
in the Alpstein,
it isn't active either,
so it doesn't mean
they're always active,
just because they're on the glider chart.
These are just those
that are used very often,
and therefore,
are permanently on the chart.
they are.
But on the day itself,
you can always quickly
check DABS,
I've got here,
as an example,
the D12 exactly,
near Einsiedeln,
nearby,
there's,
very little info about it above,
and below it,
in the legend,
we then see,
when,
and how high,
that,
therefore,
is closed,
or,
as a danger area
is declared,
and also,
when,
from when,
it's done.
I also recommend
looking,
just every once in a while,
also when you,
perhaps aren't out flying
and are at the office,
during the day,
have a look,
briefly,
I find it interesting,
you discover all sorts of things,
good.
It's just not much,
(unclear),
(unclear)
Well,
of course it is,
(unclear)
and here you can see what it looks like.
On the glider chart it's quite a tricky one.
There we said, almost not,
but stupidly it's a bit fiddly.
That's why the topic, the topic
needs to be handled a bit differently than others.
Now we've talked an extreme amount about restrictions,
about dangers, about limitations.
Now I'll say a bit on the positive side about the glider chart,
about an advantage for us paraglider pilots.
And those are the LSR for Gliders.
These are the glider zones.
They're drawn in green.
It's also an LSR,
but it isn't restricted for us.
It's restricted for instrument-flight aircraft
or instrument flight in aircraft,
and that's why it's an advantage for us,
because we can fly closer to clouds there.
We'll come to the cloud clearances in a moment.
And what that means exactly,
the LSRs are active from 1 March to 31 October.
But watch out for the time window.
It doesn't apply if, for example,
you have a really good thermal day in February
and you're flying thermals.
But you might not even be aware
that the glider zones aren't active.
So watch out, they only start on 1 March.
And also for exams, for theory exams.
But also for theory exams,
also for practical exams.
If you do the exam in winter,
it could be that the examiner perhaps
asks a slightly tricky question
about the glider zones,
which then might not be active.
They look like this,
framed in green,
and there too we have lower and upper limits
on the glider chart.
And once we're talking about LSRs,
we can necessarily move
to the topic of cloud clearances.
Cloud clearances are regulated such
that up to 300 m above ground
no cloud clearance is required.
We have to be outside the clouds at all times
and also able to make a turn-around.
So we can't fly from the valley into the clouds.
Or be half inside,
but we always have to be able to turn around.
That's very important.
Horizontal visibility must be half a kilometre,
and you must always have ground in sight.
This rule applies up to 300 m.
That's a bit unusual.
It isn't simply said,
it applies in airspace G,
but only the lower half of G.
It's only 300 m and not 600 m,
where the limit is drawn.
We have to think about that too.
Anything above 300 m,
you have to keep fairly large cloud clearances.
Vertically it's 300 m and horizontally
1500 m clearance from clouds.
In terms of visibility, it's not just half a kilometre,
but goes up to 5 km,
respectively 8 km,
as soon as you fly above 3050.
And it has to do with the speed
of the aircraft,
because higher up, faster speeds are flown
and of course you need more time
to react and to be able to avoid.
And aircraft that fly there in the clouds,
and well, when they pop out of the clouds,
if there were only 500 m clearance to the clouds,
then of course
it could get tight in some circumstances.
That's why we have higher,
larger cloud clearances.
In addition,
in the special case,
of glider zones,
all those LSR for Gliders,
it looks a bit different.
In these zones we have
a reduced cloud clearance,
namely 50 m vertical
and 100 m horizontal,
there on the right side
again the lower limit
and the upper limit
of the zone
or of the airspace.
And it's important here
that you don't just give up
or think
that now at 2450 you're always in a super thermal
that you have to fly out
and abandon.
And there, you can definitely,
climb out higher.
The only thing
that changes again,
once you're above,
are the cloud clearances.
So as soon as you're up,
for example at 2.5 km,
the big cloud clearances apply again.
Here it's also important to know,
and sometimes
comes up in theory-exam questions,
so they're set up,
so that you might mistakenly
assume,
you can only go up to 2450.
But that doesn't apply to flying,
rather it only applies to the cloud clearances
that you have to maintain.
Because many of these LSRs
don't have any extras.
And just have heights,
sometimes in standard atmosphere,
sometimes above sea level.
And some have an addition
of MON.
MON means,
it's only active
when the military
is off,
so when the military isn't active.
MON is always active
when the military isn't in.
With MON, the difference is,
if that's the case,
it can be,
that it then gets cleared straight away.
And then we have to make a request.
So if the military is active,
and MON is shown,
you can make a request.
Maybe they'll release the airspace,
because the military
perhaps isn't at that location at all
or isn't using the airspace at all,
at that point in time.
Exactly.
So, now we've heard a whole,
whole lot of theory.
I hope
I haven't worn you out.
Now we're getting to a theory question,
as a kind of warm-up for the theory exam,
and of course also for flying.
When at some point we're standing on a launch site,
and we want to know,
okay, how high can I fly there,
what cloud clearances do I have to keep,
how far do I have to see?
And am I even legal here,
or should I rather not launch.
Basically I always ask myself
five questions
when I'm at any given spot.
First, what time of year is it,
because of the glider zones.
So am I between March and October,
or am I in winter,
because that influences my cloud clearances
in a given case,
within a glider zone.
The second is the weekday
and time of day, because of the military.
To know how high I can climb,
if it's running really well today.
Then I have to know,
am I north or south
of the dividing line,
am I in the Mittelland or am I in the Alps.
The altitude I'm at right now,
is very important to know,
and also the location.
So am I,
perhaps already somewhere in the radius,
of a helipad
or am I in some kind of special zone.
And that's very important.
If you can answer these five questions
for yourselves,
then we'll get
to the solution relatively quickly.
Maybe you can pause quickly
and not move on to the next slide yet
and think through the exercise yourself.
And on the next slide
the explanation will come.
Yes, as you see,
it's standard pressure.
There's a maximum,
altitude of 3050,
because we're north of the line.
It's a bit tricky here.
It really,
goes right up to the boundary at Montreux,
but slightly,
or slightly to the left of it,
so that means,
we're in the Mittelland.
That means,
the answer with 4550
we can actually already cross off.
And quite often you get there
by what the theory exam also requires,
namely using process of elimination to find the correct answer.
Flying forbidden,
as you see here, there's no reason,
we don't have an airfield,
no helipad nearby,
we're not in a red danger zone
or whatever else might be drawn there.
Everything looks fine for flying.
Altitude is the same for B and for C.
Now we have to figure out,
how it is with cloud clearances.
We're at 2700 metres up.
That means,
the visibility is 5 kilometres.
You can see that there.
Both say 5 kilometres.
Because we're still under the three,
3050.
Or rather,
we don't need higher,
because we're in the Mittelland.
As for cloud clearances,
though, whether it's enough or fine,
we have to think,
are we in a glider zone or not.
And here it's a bit sneaky.
You might think,
we're in one.
But if you read
below,
at LSR 21 exactly,
the LSR for Gliders
only goes up to 2450 metres.
But we're already in the air at 2700.
That means,
we're above it.
We're allowed to fly.
It's not forbidden.
But unfortunately we have to
maintain the big cloud clearances.
So 300 metres and 1.5 kilometres to keep.
And that's it...
Yes,
we try
to take this approach,
to proceed by these criteria,
so you're always legally underway
and can also answer questions
for exams correctly.
Then here we have another little example.
It's now no longer about everything,
just pay attention here.
We see,
we're at 1850 metres up.
Airspace D goes from 1650 up to 3500.
So you're quickly tempted,
to say,
oh, this is forbidden,
I'm fully in the TMA,
flying is also forbidden.
Yes,
either don't launch,
or in an exam,
click 'flying forbidden' and move on.
Here we have to think it through more carefully.
Because there's the special rule here,
that works a bit in our favour.
We're at Meiringen here.
It helps of course,
if you know the chart a bit.
But you're south of the line here.
You're in the Alps.
And that's why the,
special rule comes into play,
that you can fly 300 metres below the TMA.
And as it says above,
we're at 150 metres above ground.
And in the centre absolutely legally underway.
With a maximum altitude of 300 metres above ground, of course.
There's no above-sea-level limit here,
because the ground varies too.
And if you're soaring along the ridge,
and just always keep within the 300 metres,
then we're legally underway at all times.
It's only 300 metres,
so,
cloud clearance-wise,
no cloud clearance,
fly outside the clouds,
with the option to turn around,
possible at any time, and a bit of visibility.
Yes, then we'd like to thank you for your attention.
Thanks for listening.
I hope,
and I also think,
you can take this with you on your way.
That's always the first step,
positively,
you can take that with you,
you can also take it for prep on the exam.
And then always a second step,
of course lots of fun,
in everyday flying.
And that you're always safe and legal,
as you're underway through any airspace.
Thanks again.
See you soon.